O sea, si era capaz de producir amor perdurable,
no solo una aventura, sino amor real, amor perdurable.
Pero esta era una pregunta que no me sentía capaz de responder.
Mi relación tenía apenas unos cuantos meses,
y sentía, sobre todo, que la gente planteaba la pregunta equivocada.
¿Cómo saber si seguiríamos juntos o no, y además decírselo?
Si la respuesta fuese no,
¿haría la experiencia de hacer estas 36 preguntas
menos interesante?
El Dr. Arthur Aron escribió primero sobre estas preguntas
en este mismo estudio en 1997.
Y ahí, el objetivo del investigador no era producir amor romántico.
En vez de eso, buscaba fomentar
acercamiento interpersonal entre estudiantes universitarios,
usando lo que Aron llamaba
“Apertura personal sostenida, progresiva y recíproca.”
Suena romántico, ¿no? (Risas)
Pero el estudio sí funcionó.
Los participantes se sintieron más cercanos tras hacerlo.
Varios estudios posteriores también usaron el protocolo Amistad Rápida de Aron
como una forma rápida de crear confianza e interacción entre extraños.
Ellos lo han usado entre miembros de la policía y de la comunidad.
Y lo han usado entre personas de ideologías políticas opuestas.
La versión original de la historia,
la que probé el verano pasado,
que combina preguntas personales con cuatro minutos de contacto visual,
fue citada en este artículo,
pero desafortunadamente nunca se publicó.
Hace unos meses, estaba dando una charla
en una pequeña universidad de artes liberales,
y después un estudiante se acercó a mí
y me dijo con timidez:
“Probé el estudio y no funcionó”
Él parecía desconcertado por ello.
Y yo: “¿Quieres decir que te enamoraste de la persona con quien lo hiciste?”
“Bueno…” él hizo una pausa.
“Creo que ella solo quiere que seamos amigos.”
Y yo: “¿Pero se volvieron mejores amigos?”
“¿Sentiste que sí lograron conocerse mejor tras probar el estudio?”
El asintió.
“Entonces, funcionó", dije.
Sin embargo, no creo que esa era la respuesta que él buscaba.
De hecho, no creo que sea la respuesta que ninguno de Uds. esté buscando
cuando se trata de amor.
Me topé con el estudio por primera vez
cuando tenía 29
Y estaba atravesando una separación realmente difícil.
Había tenido esa relación desde que tenía 20,
lo que suponía prácticamente toda mi vida adulta,
y él fue mi primer amor verdadero.
Y no tenía idea de cómo o si podía vivir sin él.
Así que me volqué en la ciencia.
Investigué todo lo que pude encontrar sobre la ciencia del amor romántico,
y esperaba que aquello pudiera de cierta forma vacunarme el corazón.
No sé si me di cuenta de esto en el momento…
Pensé que solo investigaba para el libro que escribía…
Pero, en retrospectiva, parece realmente obvio:
Pensé que si me armaba con el conocimiento del amor romántico,
nunca tendría que sentirme tan mal y sola como me sentí entonces.
Y todo este conocimiento ha sido útil de una u otra manera.
Soy más paciente con el amor. Estoy más relajada.
Tengo más confianza en exigir lo que busco.
Pero también puedo verme más claramente,
y puedo darme cuenta de que lo que busco es a veces
más de lo que razonablemente me pueden exigir a mí.
Lo que busco del amor es una garantía,
no solo de ser amada hoy
y de ser amada mañana,
sino de que seguiré siendo amada indefinidamente
por la persona a la que amo.
Puede ser que esta sea la garantía
sobre la que la gente preguntaba
cuando querían saber si aún estábamos juntos.
La historia que los medios contaron sobre las 36 preguntas
es que puede haber un atajo para enamorarse.
Puede haber una forma para de algún modo mitigar algo del riesgo implícito,
y ésta es una historia muy atrayente,
porque enamorarse nos hace sentir maravillosamente,
pero también es aterrador.
El momento en el que una admite amar a alguien,
una admite tener mucho que perder,
y es cierto que estas preguntas proveen de un mecanismo
para llegar a conocer a alguien rápidamente,
lo cual es también un mecanismo para que te conozcan,
y creo que esto es lo que muchos realmente queremos del amor,
que se nos conozca, que se nos perciba, que se nos entienda.
Pero creo que cuando se trata del amor,
estamos muy dispuestos a aceptar la versión corta de la historia.
La versión de la historia que pregunta: “¿Aún siguen juntos?”
Y su contenido con una respuesta de Sí o No.
Así que más que una pregunta,
propondría que hagamos preguntas más difíciles,
preguntas como:
¿Cómo decides quién merece tu amor
y quién no?
¿Cómo permanecer enamorados cuando las cosas se complican?,
y ¿cómo saber cuándo cortar y distanciarse?
¿Cómo vives con la incertidumbre
que inevitablemente conlleva una relación?
O aún más,
¿cómo vives con la duda de tu pareja?
No sé necesariamente las respuestas a estas preguntas,
pero creo que son un buen comienzo para tener una conversación
más reflexiva sobre qué significa amar a alguien.
Así que, si desean
la versión breve de la historia de mi relación, es esta;
hace un año, un conocido y yo aplicamos un estudio
diseñado para crear amor romántico,
nos enamoramos,
aún seguimos juntos,
Y estoy muy contenta.
Pero enamorarse no es lo mismo que permanecer enamorado.
Enamorarse es la parte fácil.
Así que al final de mi artículo escribí: “El amor no sucedió.
Permanecemos enamoramos porque tomamos la elección de estarlo.”
Y me estremezco un poco al leerlo ahora,
no porque no sea verdad,
sino porque en el momento, no había considerado
todo lo que suponía esa elección,
No consideré cuantas veces tendríamos ambos que tomar esa decisión,
y cuanta veces tendré que seguir haciendo esa elección
sin saber antes si él siempre me elegirá o no.
Quiero que sea suficiente haber hecho y respondido 36 preguntas,
haber elegido amar a alguien tan generoso, amable y divertido
y haber expresado esa elección en el diario más grande de EE. UU.
Pero lo que he hecho, en cambio, es convertir mi relación
en el tipo de mito en el que no creo de verdad.
Y lo que busco, y lo que tal vez pasaré mi vida buscando
es que ese mito sea verdad.
Quiero el final feliz implícito en el título de mi artículo,
que es, a propósito,
La única parte del artículo que en realidad no escribí.
(Risas)
Pero lo que tengo en cambio es la oportunidad de elegir amar a alguien,
y la esperanza de que él también me amará,
y es aterrador,
pero ese es el trato con el amor.
Gracias.